-You did Broadway stuff.
-I did.
-You did do Broadway stuff.
Well, when I was a struggling
actress at NYU drama school,
I was really determined
to make it.
So I got a -- I borrowed
somebody's Equity card,
and I made a fake Equity card
so I could sneak into Actors'
Equity and go on auditions.
Even -- And, so, because
they had auditions, open calls
for big Broadway shows,
and there was this big
new musical called "Smile,"
where they were casting girls,
you know, my age,
like 18 years old, to be the
stars of this Broadway musical.
And I did sneak in
with my fake Equity card,
and I made it really far.
It was, like, singers
who could move well
was what was required,
and I love singing.
So, I did really well
on the singing part,
and I made it down to the final,
final, final, final callback.
But for the final,
final callback,
where there were only
like 20 girls left,
we had to do the "dance" part
of the audition,
and Miss Debbie Allen
was the choreographer.
So, we got to meet her.
-A famous...
-A famous choreographer.
-Like the gold standard
of dance, really.
Yes, so, she was just like --
You know, I was like,
"Oh, my God.
This is could be my big break!
I've made it this far
with the singing
and now the dancing portion."
So, I went in,
and they were all --
Debbie Allen and all the
other executive producers
were behind a table,
and she was like, "All right."
We like your singing.
Now let's see your dancing."
And I was like, "Okay."
And, so, just freestyle.
She was like,
"Just show me your moves."
And I was like,
"Okay, just like that?
Like, no music or anything?"
So, she was like, "Nope.
Just show me your moves."
So, this is what I did.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Where should I do it?
-Just -- Yeah. Right over there.
-So, I have a dress --
I have a dress on,
so I can't really move,
but I was just like,
"Are you ready, Miss Allen?"
And she was like, "Yes."
And I was just like...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Holla!
-Holla! Holla.
-And, now, how did that end?
Was it pretty immediate
that they asked you to leave?
-She was like, "Thank you."
Like, that was it.
It was the worst.
That's a true story.
I hope I didn't show --
flash my undies.
I have a dress on,
so that was hard to do.
I wish I could have moved well.
But, you know, you get the idea.
-You should know that it was
better than what we saw.
It was very limited
by the dress.
Like that -- It was
so much better than that.
-Yes, yes, exactly.
-Yeah.
Thank you so much
for being here.
It is always just the joy
of joys to have you here.